well it's not just asking hard questions
it's also asking the follow-up questions
and it's also not embodying the
conventional wisdom the way say team
roster does I call him the conventional
wisdom zombie because he never
challenges the conventional wisdom when
his guest presented and he embodies it
in his questions so I think the press
needs to recognize that sometimes you
can get the true story without access
and if you simply sell your journalistic
credentials to get access you may end up
like Judy Miller who am had an enormous
amount of access and she got the story
completely wrong on the front pages of
the New York Times about WMD and and the
nuclear capability of Iraq etc etc or a
bob woodward who had almost unlimited
access to the White House in the lead-up
to the one completely missed the story I
call him in the book the dumb blonde of
American journalism
first of all and any politician whether
on whatever side of the aisle they are
would prefer soft questions too hard
questions the key here is our
journalists trying to get to the truth
and it's not asking hard questions for
the sake of it is not asking gotcha
questions or questions that set and the
politician up it's a question of getting
to the truth I mean that is the
fundamental and duty of a journalist and
that's all we're talking about